solo a Star Wars story was directed by a
lot of people but Ron Howard has final
credit despite Disney's involvement the
stuff with Lord and Miller that you've
probably heard about in every review
that you've read or watched that I'm not
going to get into because more than
likely you know all about it
the production was and the issues that
went on with this film and this is a
Star Wars prequel that explores the
early years of Han Solo's life his early
times with Chewbacca and Lando and how
he came to be known as a smuggler and
the baddest scoundrel in all of the
galaxy
han Solo was always one of my favorite
characters in the original Star Wars
trilogy he felt sort of like your
everyday guy who was stuck in these
larger-than-life scenarios
despite his incredible skill as a pilot
and his luck he seemed like a normal
person who was there and he related to
him he was funny charming he was a
scoundrel as always and there was
something great about Han Solo and so
naturally obviously all these years
later now that Disney has the rights to
Star Wars we're going to get tons of
adventures and right now they seem to be
only interested in exploring things that
we've heard about for years how Han Solo
got the Falcon how he met Chewie the
Death Star plans with rogue one I'm
excited to see a Star Wars story
eventually that has nothing to do with
any of the episodic films because all of
these films feel hampered by what we
expect to happen or the knowledge that
we're going to get information that
explains things we've heard about for
years or read about in books that are no
longer canon and that can be damaging to
this film in particular because rarely
ever does this film try to develop the
character of Han Solo when you have a
movie that's all about him I expect it
to justify itself beyond just a
money-making machine that Star Wars is
becoming I expect there to be a reason
beyond seeing Han Solo in some
adventures because that's really all
this movie gives us a bunch of scenes
that lead to various escapes or daring
rescues or last-minute strokes of luck
and it doesn't really do that much to
deepen Han Solo as a character that
being said you also want to be really
careful like from a right
perspective this is written by Lawrence
Kasdan and his son Jonathan caste and
now Lawrence Kasdan has written some of
my favorite screenplays of all time
Raiders of the Lost Ark The Empire
Strikes Back and so naturally I expect
something pretty strong whenever I find
his name attached to a screenplay but
this film seems to have little interest
in exploring what they could do with Han
Solo's character at the same time though
you don't want to tarnish the originals
by adding things that make what we've
already seen in the original films seem
worse or different in some way there are
certain character interactions in the
original trilogy that now have a little
more weight and a little more depth and
that's fine I'll talk about that if I
decide to do a spoiler review because
there really isn't that much to spoil in
this movie if I feel like there's more
that I want to say I'll do another video
but that was one of the more
disappointing aspects of Solo was that
it just didn't really do that much to
justify why we're having another Han
Solo movie if you're not going too deep
in the character and you're just going
to show us events that led to the Han
Solo we know and love I don't really
understand the point beyond money and
this film disappointed me on that level
this is not a terrible film by any means
I didn't hate myself watching this I
didn't loathe the experience I found the
film very average there are plenty of
impressive action sequences an extremely
exciting train sequence and a very fun
scene involving the Falcon escaping from
some stuff and you know if you somehow
don't know I won't ruin it for you even
though it's in every trailer that
sequence with everybody together trying
to get through this very difficult area
awesome stuff and yeah we all know
what's going to happen because we've
heard it said a billion times but I
think one of the biggest issues that I
had with solo was not so much Alden
Ehrenreich as solo he's fine you know I
mean he's hampered unfortunately into an
imitation of something that people
around the entire world know and love
there's not much you can do you can't
really push the boundaries you can't try
anything new because you have to
basically be something that's already
been done before because the characters
of Indiana Jones and Han Solo are so
linked with Harrison Ford that
you can't really push those boundaries
at all and do anything different I
wouldn't really say I thought he was bad
one of my biggest issues is that the
film doesn't really understand one of my
favorite traits upon solo yeah he's very
charming he's very likeable and he's a
scoundrel and he's a nerf herder and all
these things that we've heard countless
and countless times over but what a lot
of people don't really talk that much
about when it comes to Han Solo is his
perceived annoyance with the
incompetence of the people around him
he's constantly annoyed with the way
people aren't doing their jobs the way
he thinks they should what do you mean
nobody knows it's possible why don't you
go find out it's getting dark outside
that's not how the force works yeah han
Solo was likable and charming and all of
those things that he is in this film but
he's also kind of a grumpy person who
feels a little bit superior to those
around him but has a hard time
expressing that because he'd rather just
relax and do his own thing this film
understands that sort of but it chooses
to play it so flat in such a basic
comedic way without really exploring any
of the depth behind Han Solo one of the
reasons Harrison Ford wanted Han Solo to
die in Return of the Jedi originally was
because he felt that the character
didn't have that much depth behind him
and that by making a sacrifice that
would boost his character a bit George
Lucas didn't want that JJ Abrams took
that character in force awakens and I
think added a considerable amount of
depth to Han Solo's legacy that he did
not have in the original films and I
think in the end what abrams and
lawrence kasdan did for solo in the
force awakens definitely made that
character have a deeper legacy with this
film it's basically just a series of
adventures with somebody who acts kind
of like Han Solo and they don't try to
deepen this character at all Donald
Glover as Lando Calrissian is definitely
a bright spot in the film and it wasn't
just that I was looking to see if the
actors were acting
like they're you know famous
counterparts from the original trilogy
his character was just the way he should
have been
he was really good totally on point
Donald Glover is definitely one of the
best talents out there in regards to
pretty much everything he touches so far
I'm waiting for him to reveal a flaw
woody harrelson plays Beckett who has
been marketed as sort of a mentor to Han
Solo I don't really know if that's
really the right word to use for him
he's basically just someone that Han
goes on some adventures with and he
feels like he could be played by any
actor I think that may have been one of
the production issues when switching
from Lord and Miller to Ron Howard
because Lord and Miller are more famous
for their comedic tendencies and how
good they are with improv and they
choose actors who are good at that Woody
Harrelson is definitely one he can be
the bartender on Cheers and he can be
the sheriff in three billboards the
story line with emilia clark and how
that ties into solo and his upbringing i
thought was definitely one of the
strengths of the film i wish that they
had explored it more but they don't it
just feels so often like this is a
corporate film that is meant to please
the masses without taking a single risk
which is not what star wars' is to me
and yeah I think people who maybe aren't
the biggest fans of the episodic films
can go to this film and sit back and
relax and enjoy some fun battles and a
few funny sequences and some special
effects and they'll probably enjoy it
more than someone who is more interested
in the deeper themes of Star Wars like
for instance my friend who I saw it with
today really enjoyed it and he went in
expecting to hate it and again I must
reiterate I certainly do not hate this
movie I'm sure I'll watch it again
someday but it just didn't really feel
like they wanted to explore anything
that they were setting up to explore it
feels less like a narrative and more
like a series of events which is
disappointing one other really good
strength of this film is Chewbacca and
that back and forth between Solo and
Chewbacca I liked how they met I thought
it was handled really well there's a lot
of great sequences with them and the
film does its best to not
screw up anything if you know what I
mean like you you can watch solo this
movie and then go watch the originals
and you don't feel like anything's
changed or ruined
you know like certain things like his
dice and a few interactions with Lando
are going to be a little different but I
think the choices they made that could
provide some changes to the originals
are good but again there are no risks
say what you want about the last Jedi
which trust me everyone has that movie
did take risks and that was something
that I admired about it and this film
does not this is very much so a
straightforward Star Wars movie with a
character we know and love who isn't
really acting so much like the character
we know and love whenever a Star Wars
film comes along that maybe isn't as
good as it could have been and does not
reach the colossal expectations that so
many of us attribute to these films
before we see them people tend to think
it's like the worst movie ever made
that's not the case with solo tons of
people are going to be entertained by
this movie and there are sequences that
definitely entertain me but in the long
run it just didn't really justify its
existence beyond making money I'm gonna
give solo a Star Wars story of seed guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
as always you are the best and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]